- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today's message is be driven.
Over to you Jamie Foxx.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going.
- So I had to learn drive.
That's why I have my
managers to teach me drive
or to, you know, push me
because you can relax.
You could say, "Oh, I could do that"
or "I could do that."
But, are you going to be that person?
I know this person, this
person that calls me up,
"Man, did you see what
Denzel did in that movie?
He said, "I could've."
And, maybe he could have, but
he doesn't have the drive,
the Denzel, and so therefore,
if you don't have drive,
you quit cultivating your talent,
because once you rest, and
once you say it's over,
"I've gotten to the mountain top.",
then your talent starts to dwindle too.
That's why the minute the
award season was over,
I was at Wet Willies in
Miami doing jokes for people
just on the street, just
to see what would work,
you know, Jokes either about the Oscars,
or jokes about whatever,
and then you go to Atlanta
and work on your jokes there.
So, that hustle, what I call
hustle, is very important
because, at some point,
you're going to be able to
pull the hustle back just a little bit,
and then you pick your spots.
The time right now is to
hustle to set things up
so that in the future
you're able to cut back
just a little bit, and
just pick your spots.
- For me, a lot of this still
comes down to environment.
I think the environment
that you're in matters.
The people around you matters.
Again, what you're reading,
what you watch really matters
because, I think, too many people
are comfortable where they are,
and their environment
keeps them where they are,
and you don't have people
pushing you to get better,
pushing you to drive faster,
pushing you to go a little bit harder.
I think a lot of people
are just comfortable
being the big fish in the small pond,
instead of jumping to a bigger pond
and being that small fish
trying to get better.
I think a lot of people
are in a race, you know.
They're in a 100 Meter race,
and they're racing against five year olds.
So, they win all the time.
And when you are winning all
the time, in that small race,
it's easy to just stay there.
"Look at me, I'm great.
"Look at all the great stuff I'm doing.
"I don't need to work harder.
"I don't need to push faster.
"I'm already winning everything."
And for a lot of people,
that's where they are.
You know, that's where I was,
where I was doing more
than the people around me,
where anytime we'd have get
togethers, coffees, meetings,
or whatever, it was always only praise.
Like, "Oh, look at this great
stuff that you're doing."
And it's easy for me to sit back and say
"Yeah, look at all this
great stuff I'm doing.",
and take my foot off the gas.
But I want to play in the bigger game.
I want to race against Usain Bolt.
I want to race against people
who are faster than me.
And I may lose.
I'm going to lose racing
against Usain Bolt.
I'm going to lose against
people who are faster than me.
But, my time will be faster.
My time racing against
a five year old versus
my time racing against sprinters,
I may lose that race, but
my time will be faster.
So I'm getting better.
I'm pushing harder,
and, so, that's what
you need for yourself.
You want to be driven?
You want to do something bigger?
You want to push more?
You need to have people around
you who are better than you.
It's why I started the Top Ten Series
and the Mentor Me Series,
to learn from people,
to be around them, who've
done a lot more than us.
So, I look at my life,
and while I'm grateful
for everything that's happened,
and everything that's been accomplished,
I still realize that
it's nothing compared to
what all these other people are doing.
It's not looking at
those people and saying,
"Well, I suck.
"I can't go out and do that."
It's inspiration.
I can push harder.
I'm not pushing hard enough right now.
I can do more.
I'm not just going to sit back
and keep racing five year olds.
I want to go off and play a bigger game.
I want to jump to that bigger pool.
So, if you're worried that
you're not driven enough,
that you're not following
through on your goals enough,
that you don't have big enough goals,
that you don't believe in yourself enough,
look at your environment.
Look at your habits, look at your routine,
look at the people around you.
Look at what you're consuming
on a consistent daily basis.
You need to be around people and things
that push you to do more,
to believe in yourself more,
to dream bigger dreams,
to believe that those are possible,
to go and chase, to wake up
and work and hustle and drive,
for yourself, for your
family, for your community,
for the world, it's important.
So, if you're on the
lazy side, chances are
you have an environment around
you that supports laziness.
Change your environment,
start changing your life.
So the the question of the day today is,
Do you have an environment
that supports you
in accomplishing your big dreams, or not?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Also, I want to give a quick
shout out to Aurora Balogidi.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me,
and I hope it helps
you find your one word.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going